[Music]
they know this is where genji are going
to be coming from they're set up with a
triple hole back in ct
to try and shut it down automatically he
does get one nitro
swinging from in this bombs oh it's the
will hole find the final frag if they do
it will
almost guarantee the next one for them
quick scope comes in nitro
nails it and we'll see if this is going
to be enough falling low hp looks like
oh no
he's got a kick no no no no he can do
this thunders he can do this
he's coming in and i think he's done it
he's pulled it off
team liquid wins around it's nitro
with the ninja diffused from hell yeah i
don't think we would be in this position
without
without nick it's all on the jw
smoked away and it's done finally
finally liquid get there not to the
grand slam but he's got the kill
and liquid habit they've got the
championship they've got masters
and two in the intel grand slam
unbelievable scenes here ladies and
gentlemen
team liquid are your season nine pro
league champions
down to the two versus one if it's rpk
there's drop they could be in serious
trouble
that should do it there we go it's team
liquid
and that's what it means to them the
favorites coming into the tournament
have just unlocked the intel grand slam
at here
one colonel than a belt and a
million-dollar bonus
nitro is a cs go legend to try and shut
it down automatically he does get one
nitro
swinging from in this bombs oh it's the
hold for the half from nitro
four kills in the round as he turns
genji
to mince me he's been with team liquid
for half a decade but
that journey is over now for liquid
nitro's departure marks the end of an
era he's been with the team since the
beginning so the new team liquid
cs go team is going to be myself uh
dapps
nav fugly and nitro um we're a pretty
young team
so we do have a lot to prove
and you know a lot of hard work in front
of us nitro
joined team liquid in 2015 just a few
months after he almost
left pro cs go entirely at that moment
in my life i was
i think i was going into my second year
of college so i was really trying to
focus on getting
my education just because you know cs
wasn't like a big thing
at that time so i didn't really want to
just like gamble all my marbles into
some random game that like i don't know
it could die the next year
i didn't know how the game was going to
develop obviously no one knew really
and i got cuffed from above power and
that was like my ticking into the scene
and
uh luckily like i joined denial
afterward they made a spot for me and
came team liquid so i'm still here today
over the next three years
nitro saw himself surrounded by many
different iterations of team liquid
with one even including cs go god simple
but it wasn't until the end of 2018 that
he'd find himself a part of the greatest
n a team ever maybe in the chaos he'll
have a spot to do so
maybe now's the time he just heard nitro
right next to him get a kill but nitro
seems wary of this as well nitro is in
such a bad spot if they try to pinch him
there's a smoke though
he can turn his vision towards the back
and oh my god the assistance comes in
liquid have an answer for absolutely
everything
and magisk will go down and that is
gonna be a wrap liquid
acquired a cast of killers and while
they were putting together this super
team
nitro blossomed into one of the game's
greatest igls
nick's growth as the player as an income
leader
and like individual skill set is like so
intriguing i don't know
not a lot of people know like the amount
of changes like nitro has gone through
he's like a very confident offer now
like he can like stand up there and like
off against like device and simple
and like i'll play them not because like
he's mechanically good but he's just
smart
the team dominated pro cs go in 2019 not
only were they ranked first in the world
but they won what's arguably the game's
toughest title the million dollar intel
grand
slam 12 hp for rpk no diffuse kit
available here
a two versus two and liquid have the
advantage they're trying to bring it
down to the two versus one
if it's rpk there's drop they could be
in serious trouble that should do it
there we go it's team liquid and that's
what it means to them
they've taken it in the fourth map the
favorites coming into the tournament
have just unlocked the intel grand slam
at esl one cologne underneath
and a million dollar bonus in order to
capture the intel
grand slam a team must win four s-tier
tournaments in the window of 10
consecutive events
and team liquid did it in only 63 days
to put this into perspective
it took astralis one of the greatest cs
go teams to ever play the game
231 days to complete their intel grand
slam
team liquid made history for north
american cs go
they were the first n a team to
legitimately be called the best in the
world for an extended period of time
but that glory wouldn't last forever
if they can just win a single round que
serado he's gonna be tested he lines him
up
he knocks him down nitro the last man
left over at a distance
dies and furious survive
2020 has been rough for liquid their
play has declined over the course of the
year and
the moves to online only hurt them more
that that team
desperately needs something positive
they need some kind of a deep rub they
need some kind of a tournament win
um and i i just don't see it happening
at the moment they tried to mix things
up a bit by moving stewie
to the igl position unfortunately the
change didn't do much as liquid
continued to underperform against their
na competition
that's not the one you know he's doing
some damage yeah well
now it's definitely over lagged by the
op and this is it this is going to be
gen g
recovering in bts in these past two
weeks looking at a whole new level
16-9 victory over liquid on vertigo with
no signs of a resurgence
a change was made with nitro parting
ways with the roster
after five years with the team i want to
stay in the scene or
the competitive scene for that for that
matter and
we'll see what happens next peace out
now teamless for the first time in five
years
nitro's future is full of possibilities
don't forget he's stone experienced igl
whose shotcalling has helped beat some
of the world's best
he could totally find another team to
play with if that's what he wants to do
but no matter what he chooses next nitro
will forever be remembered as the leader
of one of cs go's
greatest teams he looked like captain
america out of game
and on the server he sure played like
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification
bell for unique bite size videos you
won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages